welcome everyone  thank you for joining me online to  celebrate the accomplishments of the  yale graduates of  2021 your deans and i congratulate you  for the extraordinary work you've  completed in your programs of study  we salute your effort your diligence  your talent  and your intellect we also join you in  expressing gratitude for  all who have supported you in these  endeavors your families and friends  professors and other members of the yale  community  on june 4th when you have been  recommended by the faculty of your  school  and approved by the corporation your  dean will ask me  by my official act to confer upon you  your degree by the authority vested in  me i shall confer upon you your degree  when designated by the deen and shall  then admit you  to all its rights and responsibilities  congratulations to the yale graduates of  2021  you